brandon woodruff yeah making uh start
number five against cincinnati and no
decision earlier this year he's two and
two so far career against cincinnati the
reds at the bottom of the national
league in a number of offensive
categories and that is quick work the
fastball gets bottle strike out of vato
to start the night and woodruff ahead
two strikes to castellanos and he has
back to back strikeouts to start this
tuesday evening
[Music]
is woodruff ready to deal and he will
strike out the side
oh brandon woodrow feeling good luis
castillo known as la piedra and the reds
would like to getting back to that
nickname and getting back to the
castillo numbers
one two pitch
out ahead was yelich and down he goes
craig counsel
you know recognizes this ball game as a
potential low scoring game a pitching
duel
take anything you can
perfect tunneling when you can throw a
changeup and a fastball back-to-back in
the same spot
good night irene swing and a miss strike
three and castillo has his fifth
strikeout of the night two down
most guys hit that change up off the end
of the bat castillo he'll jam you that's
how much movement it's got swing and a
mess got him on a breaking ball away
and castillo threw the first 10 batters
has
punched out
a lot of the talk lately around the reds
offense has been how the
advanced metrics show that the reds have
just been extremely unlucky offensively
the reds have runners two away and
here's mike mustakis the one-two pitch
and mustache lines one through the right
side of base hit here comes castellanos
to the plate he will score
and right behind him suarez the reds get
two on just a soft line drive single
through the right side castellanos and
suarez score it's a two for one for mike
mustakas and the reds
have taken a two nothing lead in the
fourth and the brewers have two men on
with nobody out for justin with an
opportunity here for the recently hot
justin smoke four for his last nine to
play including a couple of homers
pitch home
swing and a bouncer hit to first votto
has it throws to
second and it hits here in the back
yelich is going to come in and score
kira stands at third base
on what could have been a double play
they were at least thinking they'd get
one at second instead they get none
runners are on the corners on what will
be a throwing air on joey votto
no runners on the corners for ben gamel
gammel now one for nine
against castillo in his career
and there's a shot into right field
castiano's going back and that is off
the wall hiro will score smoke on his
way to third throw into second is cut
off run scoring double for gamble and we
are tied and nice i mean he weighed it
back nicely on it and gandel able to hit
it hard off the wall and right
and just like that the brewers tie it up
and they're in business they're in good
shape to score more nine for 23 facing
castile with seven rbis
one strike pitch
ground ball through into right field to
basic smoke is in here comes gamble
tearing around third throw to the plate
and out at home castellanos cuts him
down
at the plate
they'll a good send with two outs
gamble runs well but castillanos throws
him out
they'll pitch on the way and strike
three called he gets the inside corner
his bottle
strikes out for the third time tonight
and maybe just too patient joey votto it
looked like a pretty close pitcher on
the inside corner nick castellanos will
stand in a hit by pitch and a run in the
fourth officially zoe for one base is
still loaded one out
and a breaking ball a liner in the right
field that's a base hit galvez coming
home and the throw gets there in time oh
no he's safe at home and now narvaez
bases were loaded if the foot's on the
plate he's out
yeah because it's a force
you don't have to tag yeah ben gamble
yeah there you go he's out at home right
right oh what worked by gamble umpire
forgot it was a force
i think freddy gavin's kind of caught no
man's land
[Applause]
and line drive not sure if gamma was
going to catch it he did not
got a late break on it and gamma's throw
was right on the money
[Music]
and he popped him up
falling forward is kesten hera and the
brewers get out of trouble
williams uh three three outs last night
in the seventh inning look out the side
as a matter of fact
and that is strike three called and joey
votto has struck out for the fourth time
tonight one away
o2 pitch change up and that's another
strikeout for williams back to back for
him
two strikes hater trying to finish this
one off tonight here it comes and
there's a fly ball head back into center
field back goes garcia
at the warning track and the brewers win
it a 1-2-3-9 for hater